you still think we are inferior why are
the contradictory versions we are not
saints
but we are definitely decent people
is the u.n also part of the plot to
smear russia whatever i say
it doesn't matter to you you just don't
listen less than three months ago alexey
navalny current figurehead of the
russian opposition
collapsed from apparent poisoning on a
flight between siberia and moscow
german doctors who treated him later
said he'd ingested the nerve
agent novichok the kremlin has denied
any involvement
accusing the west of mounting
russophobia
my guest this week from moscow is
virtuslav nikenov
a member of president putin's party
united russia
and a lawmaker in the lower house of
parliament the duma
why is it that those who speak loudest
for the russian opposition
run the risk of mortal danger
[Music]
welcome to conflict zone
let's talk if we may first of all about
the
opposition figurehead alexei navalny who
fell
ill in august on an internal russian
flight
germany which ended up treating him said
it was beyond doubt he was poisoned with
one of the
novichok class of nerve agents
developed in the soviet union the
kremlin denies any
role in this if it wasn't them who do
you think it was
uh well i have many questions about that
actually i don't think much about
navalny
anyway uh do you remember
angela davis she was one of the leaders
of the american communist party back in
the
old soviet days and she was the most
important american in the soviet union
since she was the head of the communist
party
of course no one in the united states
knew
anything about angela davis or not much
so navalny is an angela davis
first place we we have a russian
electorate he's
he i'm sorry we we had a barrage of
explanations and
counter accusations about what happened
to him
mr putin apparently as for the
accusations
i ha i have i actually have a few
questions
to the german side uh question number
one
what do you mean by novichok what i i
know from
those guys who worked on this gas it is
a binary
gas yes it is composed of
two components two liquids
each of which is not poisonous
two of them of course if you drink a few
liters
of one of those liquids you can get some
stomach ache
this is a problem it becomes a poisonous
nerve gas capable of killing hundreds of
thousands of people
when these two components are combined
by an explosion
in a bomb mr nikon could we just stay
with
what happened could we just stay with
what happened because we received a
bewildering barrage of explanations and
counter accusations
mr putin told emmanuel macron apparently
that navalny may have
poisoned himself his spokesman dmitry
peskov the president
said navalny was working with the cia he
didn't offer any proof on that
and the head of your foreign
intelligence service sergey narishkin
citing so-called indirect information
said western security services
had discussed the issue of a sacrificial
victim from among the leaders
of russian opposition so implying that
it was the west that had tried to
bump him off again no proof of it no
facts no evidence
but why are the contradictory versions
coming from the russian side
well we do not have any versions at this
point
first of all we'd like to know what kind
of uh you know
uh poisoning uh substance was there
we want to to give us a formula you know
what what it was
because we just don't know what you are
talking about first place
second second question you know when
uh this guy skripal was poisoned
in salisbury they pretended it's a very
serious stuff you know they covered half
of the city with ribbons
they killed uh kat of skripal who was
allegedly the most dangerous creature on
earth
they did a lot of noise about that when
navalny
was brought into downtown berlin
in the clinic
where no person was evacuated
nobody so was he not
dangerous or that was not novichok which
is capable of killing
hundreds and thousands of people so what
happened
why well you're asking number three
of course of course the wrong person i
have i have the third questions
as well uh navalny as you know
was saved by the russian doctors and of
course
the doctors took all the samples now
in his blood whatever liquid they could
find in his body you know
we have pretty good doctors pretty they
were capable of saving navalny
we have pretty good toxicologists we
have pretty good specialists on nerve
gas they couldn't find a thing
in those substances in his blood this is
for you to study it is here
no one was even interested in that so my
feeling
i don't there is no official version of
what happened in navalny you have it
we don't have it because we don't have a
case
in order to study some legal
investigation you need to go to the
court
and present the evidence of an attempt
on a person no but we just have all
these different we just have
we ask we have all these the only
evidence we can bring
because we have all the differences we
can bring to the court is that
frau merkel said that he was uh
that he was poisoned we don't have any
evidence of that uh russia's attorneys
general's office
uh uh made five requests to the
to their german counterparts they got no
request on the data just request that
they have
data from the military uh
i do not expect german military to be
too sovereign of course uh
that he was poisoned so
you're saying this is to me it was this
is all part of a dirty western
conspiracy to blacken the name of russia
is it
i don't know what it is i just i just
asked questions to which i have no
answers
i mean sergey lavrov said we have every
reason to believe that
everything that happened to navalny as
regards nerve agents
may have happened in germany or on the
plane which
took him there why why should the west
bother why not
why should the west bother to do that
well you haven't got any evidence to
suggest the weather i don't i don't know
why
well there were many provocations
against russia recently but
um actually uh we don't we do not have
uh the fact of poisoning here in russia
he was we found no track trace of that
you know
nobody nobody was poisoned in the planer
which was flying
in the hotel nowhere his
samples of his blood are absolutely
clean
so when he got to germany for some
reason
they were they found something that
means that something was not
in russia it may be on the way it may be
there i don't know
why why are these claims that the west
is simply driven by russophobia why why
should the west
bother to try to blacken the name of
russia
are you such an attractive magnet to the
youth of the world these days that
western governments fear your
international popularity is that it
these days uh well you know
uh uh russophobia is not something new
it it it was not invented last week
or last month uh actually uh
in case of germany uh it started like
five centuries ago uh
early in the 16th century can we just
stay with the president
can we just stay with the president
please oh well uh
we cannot stay with the present because
we are living
in in a historic context
which is five at least five centuries
of russophobia in germany and in the
west
and so when it happens or something
happens in russia
uh there is of course an instinct to
blame russia on anything
russia has a presumption of guilt uh in
the eyes
of the sizeable part of the western
public and of course of all
the western media it's just just the
case it has been
a hundred years ago 200 years ago 300
years ago
even 400 years ago when there was no
media but there was
you know printed books and russia and
russia itself has done that
so now now whatever i say whatever i say
uh
well
there is always some truth in propaganda
otherwise it won't work but as i look at
the western propaganda as becoming more
and
more substantless there is no substance
in it
of course russia is is not you know
uh we are not saints uh but we
are definitely decent people
that's for sure the west also has a sort
of superiority complex
for centuries you guys thought that
we were inferior it was also manifested
in many
theories concepts uh in nazi ideology
uh and many other things and it
continues
you still think we are inferior you know
better
what is good for us you you're teaching
us you say you say we don't
need any teachers you say you're you're
decent people they
pretty severe you say the pretty severe
beating of peaceful demonstrators on the
streets of
moscow last summer summer last year
didn't help your reputation either did
it was that
really necessary were the march is such
a threat to the state
that people had to be beaten women men
uh well actually i don't remember people
being beaten here here in moscow but
i saw some pictures from the streets of
berlin
recently some 10 days ago
they were huge crowd and there was a
real beating
something you can never see during
demonstrations in russia these were
really tough
uh last weekend we saw the pictures from
the streets of paris
oh come on this was a real
beating uh for a whole year we see
the pictures from the streets of
portland oregon
from washington dc from new york and
this is
really tough you know so your answer
your in this case to all allegations
that police is the police
is always using the same methods but
russian police is much more
civilized than german french or american
as i as i see it on television really
really you you're passing a lot of laws
these days that make it harder for
opposition figures to run in elections
that was the cause of
some of the demonstrations in moscow
last year you prosecute plenty of people
who demonstrate
the deputy editor of commerce said the
other day
if you're going to become an independent
politician or if you decide to protest
against something
you will understand that it's impossible
to do this
legally why have you shrunk the space
for people to
protest or to make their demands in
public
why is this a sign of insecurity
actually
actually
this year actually this year it's quite
universal because of the
cov19 there are some limitations on
protests
uh as for the consequences for the
people protesting in russia they're not
as severe
as say in the united states or in
germany but let's go back to the laws
you passed last year
there's been a clear tightening of the
space for free expression
march last year there's been a clear
tightening of the space for free
expression i was saying in march last
year
two bills went through parliament
providing for heavy fines for anyone
blatantly disrespecting the authorities
or spreading what the authorities deem
to be
fake news are you happy with that firm
smack of government because a lot of
high officials weren't happy were they
the prosecutor general had reservations
the ministry of justice
ministry of communications were you
happy that these bills went through
uh well i don't think that
any uh regulations on demonstrations in
russia are tougher than in your country
first place we study
all the international uh regulations
all the laws passed on this substance
on that issue in every single country
russian is one of the mildest
first place second what i do
in the douma i represent the interests
of my electorate
i would never vote for a bill
except in very rare instances
which would not be supported by at least
three-fourths of my
electorate my constituency uh
this these laws of course were very
popular
inside russia because it protected
public safety
the freedom of one person ends when the
freedom of another person begins
and for that the regulation of
demonstration
has been passed in every single country
in russia
this regulation is pretty modest the
head of your human rights council
the head of your human rights council
mikhail fedortov said that arresting
people
for disrespecting the authorities
violated freedom of speech
it's it's a big step backwards isn't it
it's not doing much for your party's
approval rating according to vcion the
state pollster
uh your party is currently at just 31
approval so all the people who you say
are backing your laws
don't think much of your party's
performance these days do they
uh well speaking about the ratings of
the parties okay
35 percent of those who decided for them
for those
for which party they're going to vote
that means over 50
of uh of the electorate you know
we have quite a structured electoral
system
with more than 50 supporting the united
russia
with like 15 to 20 supporting the
communists
uh the same for the nationalists like 10
percent for for the socialists and
uh less than ten percent for the
liberals uh who are
which are too liberal to unite if they
lose the elections if they are not
popular it's their fault
they cannot unite you cannot provide a
gender they
cannot uh position themselves as a
russian
political force as navalny cannot
present himself
as a russian politician he's much more
popular in germany
than he is he is in russia his rating
never exceeded two percent
and i think uh whatever
well his rating according to about the
united states
nevada says his rating is 20 at the
moment
of course oh of course uh but
i i can tell you uh the
there is no such independent polling and
cannot be
you know uh uh my constituency is not in
moscow it's initially in ogre
i never met a single person not a single
person
who would ever support navalny or who
would ever
ask a question ask a question about him
or about the kind of question you ask
because that is
something of non-issue in the russian
federation
you ask the question which are of course
part of anti-russian campaign for sure
you support the politicians whom you
like and who are
nothing for russia he as i said is an
angela davis for russia
i'm not saying in his mind nothing else
it's one of the questions
it's not a question and as for the
opinion
of of the human rights uh whoever
any person in russia you know they may
have
their own opinion they can express it
freely as well as
as well as mr navalny cannons
you mentioned mr navalny again the u.n
has
repeatedly flagged up the incidence of
violent crimes
in russia targeting political opponents
is the u.n also part of the plot to
smear russia do you think
uh you know politics
may be difficult profession sometimes is
dangerous
we've got quite a few members of the
duma killed yes
uh some of them were not opponents of
the regime for
at all you know that happens in america
they killed a few presidents
you know it happens yes uh we don't
but you know whatever happens in russia
it is the government's fault
uh a politician get killed oh it's the
government it's the russian government
when you say uh how come
uh then on your side there is a
cognitive dissonance
you just cannot cannot understand uh you
know
in general um sometimes you are just
talking to the wall
in the west so you're a much
misunderstood russia is not evil
uh there is a cognitive dissonance oh
russia is evil of course it is
because for five centuries we were told
that there is evil
can it be not evil mr nikonov mr nicole
in august as i said we have a
presumption of guilt
which is uh which is in your eyes mr
nikonov in august 2018 the u.n committee
against torture
on which you currently have a
representative complained about what it
called the lack of a fast
effective investigation into the
killings of
anna politkovskaya and natalia
estemirova
and expressed concern concern at
reported cases of
harassment abduction arbitrary detention
torture ill-treatment and killings of
human rights defenders
lawyers journalists and political
opponents in russia
but you don't share the un's concern
about that do you
you think they just made it up do you
think it's just one more smear
of russia uh well
uh i've heard of some instances which
may be considered to be
a wrong investigation but investigations
are doing investigators are doing their
best
uh in any case whether it's
whoever it doesn't matter who
who got get gets murdered you know in
most
by the way most of the cases of
political murders in russia have been
investigated
and as you may know
many people already are in jail
in many cases including himself and
others
so there are political
killings all over the world you know
some of them
are absolutely
notorious like for example
you remember this saudi uh journalist
from
from the washington post can we can we
stay with russia can we stay with you
this is really
this was really bad you know there are
some some politicians are also
we are living in the world you know
where bad things are happening
americans by the way killed over a
million
people in iraq over a million
they killed five million people when we
talked to america what americans did
you're not responsible for a few hundred
thousand people
in afghanistan hundreds and thousands of
people
millions of people mr nikonov do you
investigate those cases
do you investigate those cases yes do
you cover this
and we ask the same question all right
and we ask the same questions of
everybody
what about torture tortures what about
tortures in guantanamo
yes yes what about tortures in abu
ghraib
mr will you prosecute those people mr
nikkinoff according to the un
russia has been spreading plenty of fear
in crimea
since you annexed that in 2014. that
report by the
committee against torture in 2018 noted
persistent
human rights violations there including
abductions
arbitrary detentions enforced
disappearances torture
ill-treatment extrajudicial killings
proud record
or just one more slur on moscow's
reputation
uh well uh first of all uh what do you
mean by the united nations
committee against torture the commitment
it's an organization of
one of i specific 100 again
93 countries
the decisions of the security council
are the decisions of the united nations
and that is
what the united nations is about it's
the decisions of the security council
and of the general
assembly you signed on the
responsibility
and secretary inside inside the united
nations
there are many organizations which are
actually secretariats
and western clubs close clubs
composed of mostly western diplomats
human rights activists and so on and so
forth you have a representative on the
humanity
against torture numerous amounts of
reports
you know we have the same reports
on almost every country we can
present them you know and producing
those reports
is a profession for many many people
really abductions arbitrary detentions
reinforced disappearances
torture ill treatment extra judicial
killings uh well
uh many cases of forced disappearance of
people in ukraine for example russia
except
no responsibility for crimea for these
things going on in crimea
is that what russia is absolutely uh
russia is absolutely responsible for the
crimea uh
there is law and order there and there
is no not according to the
against u.s not according to the
committee
that means they are producing fake
information
as all very often the case but again
whatever i say it doesn't matter to you
you just don't
listen to me because for you it's a
cognitive dissonance
you are sure that is true you know but
when i say that it is not true you say
no how come
there is a u.n commission on torture
which is a group of you know of whom and
you visit and you've investigated all
those allegations have you
you're telling me it's not true of
course uh
whatever allegation whatever crime is
investigated
in russia every instance of that
unfortunately this does not happen in
ukraine
where many many people disappeared you
know and no one
ever cared about him no united nations
commission
no deutsche valley no cnn no human
rights commission of the
council of europe whatever they were not
interested in that but
when they had a rumor of someone
tortured in the crimea
you know that that is a big case
uh in my mind it's a fake i i i know the
crimea very well
i visited many times i know what
happened there
uh there were really threats to the
people before that
but the situation in the crimea
including the crimean tatars
is much better than it used to be
these charges are in this public sphere
and this is my was my opportunity
to put them to you we have your answers
thank you thank you very much
for being on the program and giving us
your views
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you